the heads of the big tech companies get
grilled by republicans
the author of an anonymous article from
a high-ranking trump official
finally comes out and violence continues
in philadelphia i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben well we are five days away from the
national election
five days away we'll get to everything
news related in just one second first
as you know being five days away well
that means that we are in the midst
of a contentious time and that means a
lot of chaos is in the offing you know
what chaos means it means chaos for your
investments it's one of the reasons you
should be diversified i mean what
happens if biden wins what if the
outcome is uncertain for weeks which
could happen
what happens if wall street goes haywire
well that means that you should have
again diversified you should put at
least a little bit of your money
into precious metals so what are you
doing pre-election to shore up those
investments
diversifying to gold with birch gold
just like i've been telling you to do
for years wouldn't it be nice to have a
layer of security whichever way the wind
blows
text ben to 47 47 47 to get started one
of the great people at birch schools
will walk you through your conversion of
your eligible ira or 41k into a precious
metals ira
where the physical metal not etfs will
be stored securely birch gold they're my
folks they have an eight-plus rating
with the better business bureau
countless five-star reviews talk to them
they're extremely knowledgeable they can
help you
preserve your savings i trust my team
over at birch gold
call them ask all your questions get all
the information become an informed
consumer
of precious metals and then if you're
interested talk with my friends at birch
gold about investing in precious metals
and diversifying at least a little bit
text ben 247 47 47 open a precious
metals ira today again text ben
to 47 47 47 text pen
47 47 okay so
when you look at the real clear politics
polling average what you see is that
everything seems relatively stable i
mean there are kind of minor moves in
each direction
but overall things are relatively stable
biden has been somewhere between
ten and seven points in the lead really
for probably six months
seven months at this point in the
battlegrounds you're starting to see a
little bit of tightening in pennsylvania
biden is up to about a 3.5 percent real
clear politics poll average lead in
pennsylvania pennsylvania is the key
state by the way
assuming that trump wins the states that
he needs to win in the south meaning he
wins florida he wins georgia he wins
north carolina
let's say that he wins arizona okay
let's say that he does all of that
he needs pennsylvania right that is the
state that he requires in order to win
right now it's about a four-point race
in pennsylvania it seems like there's
momentum for trump in pennsylvania seems
like there's momentum for trump
in florida as well i've been predicting
for a while i think that trump
is going to win florida in georgia
there's new polling that suggests that
joe biden is super competitive in
georgia north carolina is within margin
of error
the margin in arizona seems to have
dropped just a little bit in trump's
favor
the latest polls in arizona put biden up
somewhere between two points and
susquehanna has trump up one point in
the last week
so all of these battleground states are
extremely extremely
close and it'll be fascinating to watch
on election night because
after all not all of these states are
going to count ballots in the same way
if you have a really really high count
of absentee ballots or mail-in ballots
for example
well it takes a long time to count those
if you have a close race and the mailing
ballots are still coming in
we may not know for weeks what exactly
happened in arizona we may not know for
months
what happened in pennsylvania in fact
the supreme court allowed longer
deadlines for absentee ballots in
pennsylvania and north carolina
according to the new york times on
tuesday so republicans in both states
oppose the extensions because they were
saying okay we should not allow
ballots that are coming in a week after
the election to be counted because
i mean what about when they were
postmarked what if somebody claims it
was postmarked the day after the
election but they actually voted before
the election
all this gets litigated why not just
solve that problem now that problem of
uncertainty
well according to the new york times and
a pair of decisions welcomed by
democrats the supreme court on wednesday
let election officials in two key
battleground states pennsylvania and
north carolina accept absentee ballots
for several days after election day
in the pennsylvania case the court
refused to plea from republicans in the
state that it decides
before election day whether election
officials can continue receiving
absentee ballots for three days after
november 3rd
in the north carolina case the court
lets stand lower court rulings that
allowed the state's board of elections
to extend the deadline to nine days
after election day up from the three
days originally called for by the state
legislature
the court's brief orders and the two
cases were unsigned
jamie coney barrett did not take part in
either case a court spokeswoman said
barrett did not participate because of
the need for a prompt resolution and
because she had not had time to fully
review the party's filings now this does
not mean
that there won't be litigation after the
election if these states are very close
and the counts continue
and there's an early count and then the
counts continue well then it can be
relitigated at the supreme court level
there were no noted descents in the
pennsylvania case the three justices
said the court might return to it
after election day in the north carolina
case clarence thomas samuel lido and
gorsuch said they would have granted
requests from republican lawmakers to
block lower courts
allowing the longer deadline well that
makes sense because in the pennsylvania
case it was done statutorily in the
north carolina case it was done by a
lower court
the two cases involved broadly similar
issues but in pennsylvania the question
was whether the state supreme court
could override a voting rule set by the
state legislature
in north carolina the question was
whether state election officials had the
power to alter
such voting rules in pennsylvania at
least they say that um
they may come back to that case after
the election which of course is exactly
the wrong thing
right chief justice roberts who's just a
disaster area chief justice roberts in
seeking to uphold the legitimacy of the
court by staying out of these questions
is actually making it worse because now
let's say the thing is really close
you're going to end up with bush v gore
this thing ends up in the supreme court
again
which is a disaster that this is 2020
which means the pandora's box could open
right the mummy's tomb could be unsealed
and all members of
of her all sort of manifestations of
horrific outcome
could be possible here for the country
my favorite personal is that uh is that
there's a 269 269 tie in the electoral
college this is my personal
nightmare scenario 269 269 time the
electoral college by the way
this could very easily happen this is
the case if donald trump holds all the
states that he held last time except for
wisconsin
michigan and arizona so he wins
pennsylvania and all the other states
you won last time
plus he wins the main second district
and the nebraska second district if he
does that
you now have a 269 269 tie in the
electoral college so people have been
asking what happens if that happens well
then it goes to the house of
representatives but the house does not
vote
with all of its members instead they
vote by state so state delegation
decides how to vote for the president
right now republicans hold a 26-23
advantage in state delegations
okay i think there's one that's that's
split the state delegation split right
down the middle
okay if democrats were to pick up two of
those
three and republicans hold one
then what you end up with is a 25-25
split in the house of representatives
with regard to who gets elected
president right so then
what happens well then they just keep
voting and then you keep voting until
somebody's elected president meanwhile
the senate gets to decide who the vice
president
is well there's only one problem the
senate could easily be split 50 50.
this is my favorite not going to happen
but it's insane
election scenario okay biden obviously
is a little bit worried about some of
the states that he's supposed to be
winning walking away according to
media biden has been heading to florida
the his campaign is afraid the
democratic turnout is lagging because a
lot of the early voting
is trending republican and republicans
are expected to outpace democrats on
election day so
biden is heading to florida in other
words this election is not over yet
and while the statistics from 538 and
real club politics show that show that
trump is the heavy underdog
this remains a very very close election
and it remains a close election for a
couple of reasons one is because the
media have absolutely 100 refused to
cover anything joe biden related
and that is just true that is just a
simple fact it is because the
intervention of the media and the social
media companies and corporations in this
election
has been absolutely overwhelming i mean
it's been like nothing i've ever seen in
american politics
truly it's a crazy crazy thing president
trump yesterday he said
listen you know if there's a story about
me being corrupted
everywhere in the media if there's a
story about joe biden being corrupt it
is nowhere in the media he's absolutely
right about this here's president trump
campaigning yesterday
tremendous corruption on behalf of the
biden
tremendous do you know you can't find it
anywhere in the media
other than the new york post which i'm
very proud of and they endorsed me the
other day too by the way
but you can't find it anywhere in the
media
sleepy joe biden with all the corruption
all the theft all the money they took
out of these countries
that we end up paying for in spades
you can't find it on big tech and you
can't find it at the washington post the
new york times
because they're crooked they're
dishonest and we caught them
okay and then trump points out he's not
just running against biden he's running
against the mob and he's running against
the media
and again there's a lot of truth to this
okay the institutional obstacles to
trump are extremely high the media have
treated trump with absolute disdain from
the time he declared for the presidency
and then once he was president they
decided that they were just going to
cover him in the most
horrible possible way sometimes critical
media
coverage of trump is justified i'm not
going to sit here and pretend that i
think that every time the media
criticized trump is unjustified i don't
think that's right
i've been very much opposed to trump
suggesting that bad stories about him
are by definition fake news i don't
think that's correct either
it is also true the overwhelming
majority of media coverage has been
anti-trump
and that extends to stories that are
overt positives for the united states
when the economy is good
the story is framed as well the economy
would be better if a democrat or
president
or republicans pounce on good economy if
the story is middle eastern peace
the story is really about how the
palestinians are being abandoned or some
such
okay here was trump yesterday saying
he's not just running against biden he's
running against the mob and the media
and this of course is true
i'm not just running against joe biden
i'm running against the left wing
mob and the left-wing media the big tech
giants
and i'm also running against the rhinos
you know what a rhino is
a rhino may be the lowest form of human
life
okay so yeah he's going after you know
the lincoln project
characters there which of course
president trump has uh his list of
enemies
and he's going to go down them but when
he says that he is facing overwhelming
institutional obstacles
he's not wrong about that one of those
overwhelming institutional obstacles
that has utterly come out of the closet
in this election cycle is social media
so social media has basically decided to
suppress stories
that they think are going to benefit
trump and this is all about 2016. if
hillary clinton had one in 2016
social media would be happily in favor
of the first amendment they'd be happily
in favor of allowing all sorts
of variant material on social media but
hillary clinton lost in 2016 and so the
democrats decided they had to blame
somebody who was not hillary clinton
first they blamed the russians then they
blamed the social media companies for
allowing the russians
to skew the election they suggested that
facebook was responsible for hillary
clinton losing because of course
facebook allowed people to put up
dissenting opinions about hillary
clinton
because facebook had not shut down
russian interference now let's be real
about this russian interference on
facebook did not lose the election for
hillary clinton
hillary clinton lost the election for
hillary clinton she's a terrible
candidate and then james comey in the
last week of the election dropped a
bombshell
suggesting a new laptop had been found
with her hidden emails right so
turns out that lost the election for
hillary not a bunch of russian scam
artists putting up
very poor by the way poorly trafficked
memes on facebook it doesn't matter
the social media giants were brought to
heal by the democratic party they were
told it is your fault if donald trump
wins re-election
and thus in the lead-up to the election
you must prevent donald trump from
winning
by any means message necessary and that
means playing up all bad trump news and
playing down any bad news for joe biden
up to and including suppressing actual
full
full-on stories from the new york post
we'll
talk about that in just a second because
the big tech heads were were
called before congress yesterday it
didn't go well for them particularly for
jack dorsey
over at twitter we'll get to that in
just one second first
let us talk about the fact global
pandemics civil unrest politicians
infringing on your inalienable right to
defend yourself
now more than ever emotions are running
high in our country see it on the news
peaceful protests
supposedly turning violent riots in the
streets law enforcement not staffed to
handle all emergencies
more and more americans are purchasing
guns and making the choice to protect
themselves and their families and they
absolutely should
if you're one of the people who's
purchased a gun recently the big
question is are you prepared you need
proper education it's not enough just to
own a gun you
need to know how to use it you need to
have industry-leading training to ensure
your skills are sharp and
you need the nation's best legal
protection should you god forbid find
yourself in a circumstance
in which you've had to fire your gun in
self-defense you need the uscca get
started today
text gun to 87-222 you'll receive the
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide for free
in this guide you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive the mass shooting seven firearms
drills that could save your life
and much much more it's 164 pages it
comes with the bonus audio version so
you can listen whenever you want
in addition if you text right now you'll
be entered to win a thousand dollars to
put toward a gun of your choice that you
can use to protect your family today
text gun to 87222 right now uscc is a
wonderful organization you should get
involved
text gun to 87 222 gun to 87
222 to get started okay so
the social media companies most
obviously i mean there's been a lot of
people on the right who've been
complaining for a while that social
media companies
are utterly non-transparent that many of
the social media companies seem to
downgrade information they simply do not
like
that all broke out into the open over
the last two and a half weeks after the
new york post
ran the hunter biden emails after the
new york post ran the hunter by an email
story
suggesting that hunter biden's emails
made reference to joe biden receiving
money
or or interest held in escrow for him
in case of a deal with a chinese company
after his vice presidency
when that story originally broke in the
new york post it was immediately banned
on twitter like outright ban you could
not tweet the link the new york post
account was shut down on twitter on
facebook the head of content over there
andy stone
put out a tweet saying that the story
had been suppressed on facebook pending
a fact check even though there was no
information to suggest that the story
was false or that it was russian's
disinformation
it was the most obvious example of
election interference by the big tech
companies
i've ever seen i mean it's it's
unprecedented absolutely unprecedented
so yesterday the big tech heads were
called before congress now
let's be real about this there has been
a push from the left to
curb big tech for a while i've been very
much opposed to that
that push the reason is that the left
would like to curb at big tech
by preventing them from posting material
what they would like is a reinstitution
of the old fairness doctrine
the idea being that you have bosses at
the federal government who tell you what
kind of content you can and cannot post
and so i've been very much opposed to
the government getting into the
regulatory business with regard to big
tech
on the right there have been complaints
that these big tech companies are being
unfair
and that they're not being transparent
in their standards there's particularly
an objection to the section 230 language
section 230
suggests that platforms are not
responsible for the content that is
posted on those platforms and that they
are allowed to content curate and
content moderate
in order to prevent the posting of
pornographic uh
violent harassing or and this is the
phrase that matters otherwise
objectionable material that catch-all
phrase has been used by the companies to
basically say we can take down anything
we don't like
and this has led some people to say okay
well now you have basically violated the
contacts with the american people you
said that we could post whatever
we wanted so long as it wasn't violent
or harassment
or incitement to violence but otherwise
objectionable is too broad if you're
just taking down my story because you
don't like my story
now you're essentially doing the same
job that the new york times would do
right you're censoring content on the
basis of political persuasion
and that really is not what section 230
was written for section 230 was written
in order not to disadvantage companies
that wanted to take down violent
or obscene material it was not written
in order to provide advantage
for publishers masquerading as platforms
right that was the basic idea
behind section 230. so right now there's
a push in the united states senate to
make clear the otherwise objectionable
standard the otherwise objectionable
standard in section
230 so that's been the push from the
right so all this comes to a head
yesterday
in this hearing with big tech now
normally hearings with big tech they go
very poorly for the congress people
and the reason they go poorly for the
congress people is because congress
people tend to be on average about 55 to
60 years old which means that they have
to call their grandchildren
in order to actually install aol on
their computer because they still have a
dial-up modem
right the the fact is that unfortunately
our congress people are not particularly
in touch when it comes to technology and
so the questions they ask are very often
quite silly however the questions
yesterday were very easy to answer and
they were why are you downgrading
particular political content
what is the excuse for downgrading for
example that new york post story there
is no plausible explanation
other than a political drive to censor
material from the left
okay so mark zuckerberg the facebook was
asked about this he was asked
specifically
you know this originally was was put on
the article was
was basically uh it was
essentially reduced in in its reach
because
you were suggesting that maybe it was
fact-checked false or it would be
fact check or russian's disinformation
or something like that so they asked
zuckerberg like do you have any evidence
whatsoever that this thing was russian
disinformation or that
actually there was that there was
anything false in the story and
zuckerberg was like no we don't have any
of that information
is that also your answer mr zuckerberg
did you have no information at all
to indicate that that russia was the
source of this
um the new york post article
senator i would rely on the fbi to make
that
assessment but you you don't have any
such information do you
i do not myself okay so there is no
information to suggest that this story
was false or russian disinformation it
was downgraded by facebook anyway
he says zuckerberg took a few licks but
the person who really took some hits
yesterday
was jack dorsey which makes sense at
least zuckerberg has paid lip service to
the idea of the first amendment
mattering
at least he has a tendency to gravitate
toward more free speech rather than less
free speech that doesn't mean i agree
with all zuckerberg's policies on
facebook i mean right now daily wire is
being dramatically downgraded in traffic
for some unknown reason
by facebook in the lead up to the
election this i do not find particularly
surprising it's been happening for weeks
on end
and we never get any transparency from
facebook okay but when it comes to
twitter
okay twitter is perfectly obvious in its
political bias like perfectly and
clearly obvious and it's political bias
so in a second we're going to get to the
testimony of jack dorsey
who uh who apparently survived the uh
the
communist and white russian attempt to
uh to take down the taurus regime
rasputin is alive and running twitter
we'll get to that in just one second
first it's time to replace your bad
employees
i know you know it's a really
interesting employment market right now
people are looking for jobs
and that means that if you're an
employer it's time to upgrade your
employees so let's say that you have a
really really good-hearted employee
somebody like rebecca rebecca's just a
good-hearted person rebecca is also the
type of person
who you know goes to parties in south
beach and is surprised to find herself
in a situation where somebody's been
murdered a similar party at the same
house like just a few months back
all of that's very good but it could put
rebecca in peculiar situations that
require you to replace
rebecca and this is why you would need
ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter does all the work for you
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job unzip
recruiter gets sent out to over 100 job
sites with just one click
then zip recruiter's powerful matching
technology finds people with the right
skills and experience
for your job and actively invites them
to apply so you get qualified candidates
fast it's no wonder four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate within
the very first day right now you can try
zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
dailywire they're doing a fantastic job
connecting prospective
employers to prospective employees go
check them out right now for free at
ziprecruiter.com
daily where zipper crew is indeed the
smartest way to hire okay so jack dorsey
straight from the side of duck dynasty i
was testifying before congress and made
perfectly clear what social media
agenda is and the thing is when you
exist in a bubble like jack dorsey is
like in a cave in malaysia being bitten
by mosquitoes and smoking dope
and all your liberal friends are telling
you you're doing some good for the world
by suppressing content
then you you literally do not understand
why people would be so upset at you jack
dorsey did not understand why people
were so upset at him
this by the way is the same guy who's so
political he hired deray mckesson
at one point uh the the racial
commentator shall we say to ray mckesson
as one of the chief voices
to decide what kind of content was
appropriate for twitter so jack dorsey
acknowledged the problem at twitter is
that republicans don't trust us yes you
think
i can't imagine why republicans don't
trust you when you literally
barred the new york post from posting
for three weeks
because they put up a story that was
true here is jack dorsey
apparently straight from treasure island
ben gunn here
section 230 gave internet services two
important tools
the first provides immunity from
liability for users content
the second provides good samaritan
protections
for content moderation and removal even
of constitutionally protected speech
as long as it's done in good faith
that concept of good faith is what's
being challenged by many of you today
some of you don't trust we're acting in
good faith that's the problem
i want to focus on solving how does
services like twitter
earn your trust well let's see how do
they earn our trust uh how about this
how about complete transparency
how do you know why you ban material how
you don't downgrade material and then
keep downgrading the material and keep
banning the outlet because you don't
like the political content
okay the dorsey himself acknowledged
there is no evidence that the new york
post story was disinformation none
senator ron johnson asked him directly
about it did anybody have any
any information whatsoever they're not
authentic or that they are russian
disinformation
mr darcy we we don't you know
so so why would why would you censor it
why did you prevent that from
being disseminated on your platform that
is supposed to be
for the free expression of ideas and
particularly true ideas
we believe to fill a foul of our hacking
materials policy
okay so it's it's not their hack
materials policy because it was then
followed up upon
and uh it was like uh so hold up you're
saying it's the hack materials policy
that this was hacked
you covered the steel dossier that was
no problem you covered trump's tax
returns
that was no problem it's a crime to leak
other people's tax returns you covered
that no problem
so that's obviously crap my favorite
claim by jack dorsey
uh straight from apparently rabbinic
school uh is
that that twitter does not affect
elections okay if they didn't affect
elections
then literally they would not have these
policies the whole reason that twitter
implemented these policies is because
democrats claim they affected elections
here's ted cruz asking dorsey about it
does twitter have the ability to
influence elections
no you don't believe twitter has any
ability to influence elections
no we are one part of a spectrum of
communication challenges that people
have
so you're testifying to this committee
right now that that twitter when it
silences
people when it censors people when it
blocks political speech that has no
impact on elections
people people have choice of other
communication channels
okay that is uh that is delicious i'm
just it is wonderful that now
now twitter is claiming they have no
ability to affect elections
sure sure you don't okay and this is the
problem they do have the ability to
affect elections
and they have no standard practice what
they censor this is something dorsey
also said
he said there's literally no stan we
just kind of censor what we please here
he was explaining
in some cases algorithms take action uh
in other cases achievements do in some
cases it's a pairing of the two
there are numerous examples of blue
check marks blue check marks that are
spreading false information that aren't
flagged so
and twitter must have some kind of list
of priority accounts that it maintains
you have the
blue check mark list how do you decide
how do you decide when to flag a tweet
you got into that a little bit is there
a formal threshold of retweets or likes
that must be met before
a tweet is flagged no
so they have no actual standards okay so
basically it's all arbitrary but why
don't you trust
us well maybe one of the reasons that we
don't trust you is because you will ban
the new york post but then
you will suggest that holocaust denial
is not misinformation worthy of banning
that's something jack dorsey also said
so again here's jack dorsey i mean this
guy is in charge of a billion dollar
company
wow america's an amazing country it it
truly truly is straight from castaway
island jack dorsey somebody denying the
murder of millions of people
uh or instigating violence against a
country as a head of state is not
categorically falling in any of those
three misinformation or other categories
twitter has
not misinformation but we do have other
policies around incitement to violence
so somebody denies the holocaust has
happened is not misinformation
it's it's misleading information but we
don't have a policy against that type of
misleading information
uh there's no policy with regard to
misleading information with regard to
holocaust denial but if the president of
the united states put something about
something up about kovid that twitter
doesn't like then they put a warning on
the information i can't imagine why
people don't trust twitter
why don't people trust twitter my
favorite thing here is uh when dorsey
says that the new york post is allowed
to tweet their story okay first of all
it's not true people tried to tweet the
original link yesterday it was still
banned
second of all he says what new york post
has to do is they have to delete their
original tweet with the story and then
they'll be reinstated
and then they can retweet the same link
over again or you could you know
not ban them that would be the solution
to that here's the worst member of zz
top
explaining the new york post is still
blocked from tweeting
two weeks later yes they have to log
into their account which they can do
at this minute delete the original tweet
which fell
under our original enforcement actions
and they can tweet the exact same
material from the exact same article and
it would go through
okay so the new york post is supposed to
delete its original true tweet
and then retweet the same thing so that
twitter will let them back in it's just
orwellian nonsense
now the best part about the orwellian
nonsense is all of our media bettors the
same people who declare that donald
trump is a threat to the free press
a threat to the first amendment the
press wants this the press
wants the big tech pros to shut down all
other methods of dissemination of
information that are not mainstream
media
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about protecting your
home there are a thousand reasons
that protecting your home matters to you
so i have
three young children three children
under the age of seven if you have young
children
you know they are little suicide
machines all they are attempting to do
all day long
is do dangerous things and kill
themselves it is very important to me
that i'd be able to keep an
eye on them no matter where i am and
this is what ring does
for me whatever you call home ring has
everything you need to protect it you
can see and speak to whoever's at your
front door from anywhere video doorbells
you can keep an eye on every corner of
your house with easy to install indoor
and outdoor cams
you can protect your whole home with
ring alarm a powerful affordable whole
home security system
you can easily install yourself we have
ring devices all over our house it makes
me feel safer makes my wife feel a lot
safer
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kid ring.com
ben you're keeping your house safe
inside and out it comes with rings video
doorbell 3
and chime pro it's the perfect way to
start that ring experience plus
free two-day shipping go to ring.com ben
again that is ring.com go check them out
right now
ring.com when you use that slash pen you
get a special offer on that ring welcome
kit to make your life
calmer and more secure ring.com go check
them out
right now okay so the me it's not just
that social media
are downgrading conservatives are
suppressing material that's bad for joe
biden
it's that the media love this the media
are happy with it the left
generally is very very happy with this
there are people like kevin russo at the
new york times and kara swisher at the
new york times
and jungle goblet of german william who
spend
all day just trying to pressure social
media into preventing the determination
of information
they don't like these are quote unquote
free speech activists who spend their
day trying to suppress
free speech and free dissemination that
is what they attempt to do it's their
goal in life
they love it okay and this is how you
end up with a tweet from charlie warzell
over at the new york times who covers
information wars he tweeted out
yesterday
the new york post leaving a violating
tweet up in order to stay locked out of
an account in order to use it as a
political cudgel is a classic tactic but
it's usually one you see from individual
mega influencers oh so so
what you see here is that the new york
post
refuses to take down a true story
because
they want twitter to actually just
reinstate them and that's the fault of
the new york post
incredible journalism tremendous
tremendous journalism there from charlie
warzell
who covers the information wars for the
new york post the democratic senators by
the way should scare the hell out of you
so the republican senators yesterday
were angry at the big tech bros for not
allowing more speech on their platforms
right there they are concerned at the
political discrimination on the
platforms and so they would like to see
more speech not less speech on the
platforms
the left has no such compunction not one
democrat
on this senate committee questioning big
tech
asked for consistent standards on what
is banned and what is not ban
instead they just sought to ban material
they don't like make no mistake about it
when it comes to first amendment values
not first amendment is a matter of law
which of course is about government
compulsion a first amendment value
system that values free speech
that values free and open debate the
left has no part of it the mainstream
democratic party is now rejecting it ed
markey senator from massachusetts
he says the problem isn't that you're
taking too many posts down over twitter
the problem is you're leaving too many
posts up over at twitter ed markey wants
to make sure that everything he doesn't
like is taken down over at twitter
the big tech business model which puts
profits ahead of people
is a real problem anti-conservative bias
is not a problem the issue is not
that the companies before us today are
taking too many posts down
the issue is that they're leaving too
many dangerous posts
up in fact they're amplifying harmful
content
so that it spreads like wildfire and
tortures
our democracy okay so yes the left has
no interest in free speech they don't
like free speech so here's senator brian
schatz democrat from hawaii and
full-fledged idiot
trying to suggest that these social
media companies
require more protection from
conservatives conservatives are trying
to
force twitter to allow material about
hunter biden and that means
that they're trying to make all these
social media companies into weapons
against joe biden and that can't be
allowed that simply can't be allowed
what's happening here is a scar on this
committee
and the united states senate what we are
seeing today
is an attempt to bully the ceos of
private companies into carrying out a
hit
job and a presidential candidate by
making sure that they push out
foreign and domestic misinformation
meant to influence the election again i
am enjoying the specter of
democrats suggesting that the problem
here is conservatives bullying
corporations
literally the entire democratic party
right now is trying to bully
corporations into doing things that they
want
they're trying to bully corporations and
putting up black squares they're trying
to
bully corporations into hiring ibramex
kennedy for 20 000
diversity training sessions they're
trying to bully corporations
into not opening chick-fil-a isn't
supposed to open
in chicago or boston or a variety of
other democratic cities
because the founder dan cathy supported
traditional marriage i mean it's amazing
but now apparently they're very much in
favor of private corporations being able
to run businesses as they see fit
unless you're a baker who just doesn't
want to bake a cake for a gay wedding in
which case you should go to jail or your
business should be shut down
the hypocrisy of these folks knows no
bounds none
all of this prompted ted cruz to finally
go off on the big tech bros particularly
jack dorsey
saying you know who the hell elected you
like who made you in charge of
what material the american people can
and cannot see literally the exemption
that is provided to you
is dependent on you not being an
editorial oversight board for the
american people
you can censor the new york post censor
politico presumably you can censor the
new york times or any other media outlet
mr dorsey who the hell elected
you and put you in charge of what the
media are allowed to report and what the
american people are allowed to hear
and why do you persist in behaving as a
democratic super pac silencing
views to the contrary of your political
beliefs
um that is a good question but it's not
a question that the big tech guys are
ever going to have to answer if the
democrats have their way the big tech
companies will just become an extension
of the new york times
the only links you will be allowed to
tweet are links from cbs news abc news
nbc news
and the new york times okay speaking of
the new york times
remember that time that the new york
times printed an article from anonymous
anonymous was a high-ranking
trump official you recall this it was
very very important
we were told it was very important it
was an op-ed written september 5th 2018.
i am part of the resistance inside the
trump administration i work for the
president but like-minded colleagues and
i have vowed to thwart
parts of his agenda and his worst
inclinations
and uh the uh this was described as the
writer is a senior official in the trump
administration
so for years there's been speculation
who is anonymous who's anonymous well
chris chaliza
put out a piece suggesting that perhaps
anonymous
was mike pence i mean this wouldn't be
like a low-level official because
absolutely the new york times wouldn't
just print
some missive from a low-level trump
official and then call them a senior
official
in order to get a trump it would have to
presumably be someone very high level
there was speculation
melania trump did it or victoria coates
or somebody else who had served inside
the trump administration
whose name actually might be known well
now we know exactly who this was
apparently the person is named miles
taylor yes i know the miles taylor
the very famous miles taylor senior
trump official who you have never heard
of in your entire life
he was chief of staff to department of
homeland security secretary christian
nielsen but he was not when he wrote the
op-ed
by the time he wrote the op-ed he
actually was just like
a consultant he was a dhs policy advisor
a dhs policy advisor and they
characterized him as a senior trump
official
the new york times these are the people
you ought to trust
so taylor has now put out a statement he
says much has been made of the fact that
these writings were published
anonymously the decision wasn't easy
i wrestled with it i understand why some
people consider it questionable to levy
such serious charges against a sitting
president
under the cover of anonymity but my
reasoning was straightforward and i
stand by it
issuing my critiques without attribution
forced the president to answer them
directly on their merits or not at all
rather than creating distractions
through petty insults and name calling i
wanted the attention to be on the
arguments themselves no actually what
had started was a mole hunt
inside the trump administration that was
a complete waste of time for everybody
involved by the way miles taylor's a
damn liar he went on cnn and overtly
denied that he was anonymous
not all that long ago on air with
anderson cooper cnn has announced he
will retain his slot because lying about
this is apparently of no con i mean if
you're in the media and you're in the
good graces of the media
you're basically unfireable i mean
jeffrey tubin could literally pull out
his
and and go to town on himself in the
middle of a zoom meeting at the new
yorker
and the guy was suspended right he was
not fired miles taylor goes on cnn and
lies about him being anonymous and then
he reveals on cnn that he is in fact
anonymous and they're like oh okay well
all right
no problem we here at cnn we know an
apple is an apple and a banana is a
banana
so here is uh anderson cooper with miles
taylor not all that long ago
miles taylor denying that he was
anonymous
there was an op-ed there was a book by
someone calling themselves anonymous
are you aware of who that is
i'm not look and i that was a a parlor
game that happened in washington dc of a
lot of folks trying to think
of who that might be i've got my own
thoughts about
who that might be but uh you know we're
not you're not
president and i certainly don't want to
i i wear
a mask for two things anderson
halloweens
and uh pandemics so no so no
he is he lied directly to anderson
cooper and they're just keeping him
employed at cnn because he doesn't like
trump
it's amazing don't worry our media are
completely unbiased they're absolutely
unbiased which in a second brings us to
the situation in philadelphia i
understand that our media have a vested
interest in not covering what's going on
in philadelphia it's happening in a
swing state maybe the most important
swing state
in this election so they are just going
to completely miscover everything that
is going on in philadelphia it's very
important
that it not be covered that there are
mass riots and looting going on
in america's sixth largest city because
that city resides
in a state that trump might win it might
re-elect him we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that everyone these days is pretty
aware that you need to wash your hands
what about
the third hand that you never wash your
phone now you bring that phone pretty
much everywhere you're using it in the
bathroom and you never
wash that phone do you well germs they
agglomerate on the phone they could get
you sick
why not clean your phone with phone soap
phone soap is the original patented and
clinically proven uvc phone sanitizer
they've been making phone sanitizers for
the last decade
phone soap uses uvc light and their
patented and clinically proven
technology to kill 99.99
of germs like e coli salmonella and the
cold and flu virus
phone soap can sanitize and charge your
phone in as little as five minutes
phone soap is the only consumer uv
sanitizer with a 360 degree disinfectant
chamber that uses two pieces of quartz
glass to suspend your phone making
sure all sides are disinfected it can
also sanitize tv remotes
keys earbuds credit cards other common
household objects that need
disinfection phone soap makes a lot of
different models for everybody the phone
soap 3 sanitizes in 10 minutes
the phone soap pro kills 99.99 of
bacteria in five minutes
the home soap is big enough to sanitize
tablets toys bottles
and more don't get the knockoff products
get phone soap at phonesoap.com
use promo code shapiro to save 20 and
you receive
free shipping it makes a great gift it
also offers a lifetime warranty phone
type offers a lifetime warranty
on their bulbs go to phonesoap.com
remember to use the code shapiro
save 20 and free shipping that is phone
soap.com remember to use the code
shapiro to save
20 okay we're going to get to everything
philadelphia
related in just one second but first
let's talk about the fact that the
country feels like it's coming apart
because it is right now we have a
conflict of visions there's one side of
the country that would like to see the
entire country fall apart
they don't like founding philosophy they
don't like america's culture they do not
like america's history they think all of
these things are bad
i'm not talking about people who are
just liberals people you disagree with
on tax rates i'm talking about a hard
left
that believes that america needs to be
torn down to its root these are
disintegrationists
and they are facing off against people
who would like america to remain because
they believe that america's philosophy
is unprecedentedly good if you want to
learn about this you need to pick up my
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps people say what's the single
best book i can get
like my high school or college kid so
they understand american philosophy and
what america is all about and what the
threat is
this is the book okay i wrote it for
that purpose how to destroy america in
three easy steps it's not about the
election it's about much more than the
election
it's about beyond the election it's
about the battle of ideology that is
going to characterize the country
for the next decade minimum how to
destroy america in three easy steps go
pick it up
right now over at amazon or anywhere
else that books are sold meanwhile
the presidential election is almost here
we have an amazing day of programming
for you our live stream starts on
tuesday november 3rd at 3 pm eastern 12
p.m pacific featuring special guests
live interviews and more
leading up to our evening show we'll be
covering the results with you in real
time it should be an exciting evening
even better
join dailywear right now get 25 off with
code election so you can watch all of
our election coverage
live on our apple tv or roku app members
get our articles ad free
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show
exclusive reader's past content
available only to daily wire members if
you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night
for online and live stream discussions
with our hosts an amazing online
community you also get not one but
two leftist years tumors with your
membership as well as early sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products so
head on over watch the election with us
at dailywire.com get 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you sign up today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so when president trump has been saying
that he is up against not just joe biden
but also up against
social media and big tech and the media
he is not lying
the latest indicator of a media that
does not wish to cover stories it does
not wish to cover
is what's happening in philadelphia so
you've had massive rioting over the past
three nights over the shooting
of walter wallace okay walter wallace is
being portrayed by democrats as a very
nice guy
a very very nice guy here's bernie
sanders tweet on walter wallace
so bernie tweeted out walter wallace
would be alive today and our thoughts
are with his loved ones
the police responsible for murdering him
in front of his mother instead of
getting him the medical attention he
needed
should be arrested investigated and
prosecuted by the justice department
okay so bernie sanders says this guy is
murdered murdered like in cold blood
like they should be prosecuted federally
by the justice department
says bernie mcsanders okay there's only
one problem he was holding a knife they
told him put down the knife many times
he was then 10 feet of them
he kept approaching them they shot him
also
it turns out that walter wallace was not
the world's nicest man
i know that we have this um this duty
every time
a black man is killed by the police to
portray that black man as
the font of all good innocence and
wonder
we got this with jacob blake who turns
out was an alleged rapist
we got this with george floyd and it
turns out that george floyd literally
held the gun to the
stomach of a pregnant woman a few years
prior so that does not mean that what
happened to george floyd should have
happened to george floyd
it does mean that it does not require
you to treat people who are shot by the
police or killed by the police or die in
police custody
as wonderful wonderful people in order
to make your point about police
brutality with regard to george floyd
it certainly means in the case of jacob
blake that you know the democratic
candidates
calling up jacob blake personally to
offer their condolences to him on being
shot after he resisted arrest went for a
knife in his car
and had been called to the scene by a
woman who alleged rape against him
previously
that's it it makes for a weird narrative
well it turns out that
walter wallace was not world's nicest
human being according to 6abc.com right
local news covering this wallace was an
aspiring rapper with social media
accounts filled with videos
that sounds nice doesn't it well oh well
oh yeah guns are a central theme as he
rhymes about shooting people including
police
but his videos also include songs about
social causes and police and justice
see this has always been weird to me if
you cut a song
about how you're shooting the police and
then you're like but the police are mean
to me
i feel like the police might have a
reason to be mean with you if you're
talking literally about
how you want to shoot them and murder
them in any case it's not just about his
rap obviously
people rap about a variety of topics
many of them wrap fictionally
walter wallace has a criminal record
court records show wallace was currently
awaiting trial for allegedly threatening
to shoot a woman and her house up
in 2017 he pled guilty to robbery
assault and possessing an instrument of
crime
after kicking down the door of another
woman and putting a gun to
her head he was sentenced to 11 to 23
months behind bars
in 2013 he pled guilty to assault and
resisting arrest after punching a police
officer
in the face so um yeah
that's uh that's not great that's not
great bob okay but
all of this resulted in massive riots in
philadelphia
and um our media covered it in exactly
the way you've become accustomed to our
media covering riots they decided to
downplay it pretend that it was the
looting was the was the language of the
oppressed when you're that oppressed
like in philadelphia or democrats have
been in charge for almost literally ever
well that means that you're oppressed
enough that you got to steal a tv so new
york reporter tweeted out new york times
reporter reporter tweeted out
why are we even covering this eric
lipton watching my twitter feed since
last night
very notable the intensity of tweets
from conservative voices looking to
amplify
draw attention to looting in
philadelphia yes it happened new york
times covered it as well
just remarkable how conservatives want
to elevate it i feel like it's more
remarkable
how the media wants to downplay it
massive riots in which a thousand people
loot a walmart
after the justified shooting of a person
trying to attack police with a knife
it seems to me like that should be more
newsworthy than the
top story that the new york times and
everybody else was covering yesterday
which was trump held a rally in omaha
and the transportation was not good and
some old people were stuck in the cold
that was literally the top story on
twitter all day yesterday all day
right so there's massive rioting which
is an act of mass criminality in
philadelphia
and the local authorities look the other
way or cater to it
that's not a story it's a story that the
transportation plans in omaha were not
very good
huge huge break yes don't worry there is
no media bias virginia there there's no
media bias whatsoever
then there's uh the idiots like wolf
blitzer my favorite is when joe biden
talking points just sort of
wander their way in via the media so
here's wolf blitzer saying i don't
understand why the philadelphia officers
didn't just shoot to wound
the reason you don't shoot to wound
idiot is because you're not that good
with a gun
no one is that good with a gun nobody is
jack bauer other reasons you shoot for
center of mass
because if you shoot to wound there's a
better shot that you miss and hit an
innocent bystander
there are many reasons you should other
reasons to shoot not to wound
because sometimes you wound the person
and they keep coming after you let's say
they shot this guy in the leg and he is
now within three feet of them with a
knife because he's approaching them
is that going to work out well i think
now but here's will blitzer being a
complete dunder head because this is
what we do in the media now
walter wallace had a knife as we saw one
witness said though he had mental health
issues the district attorney said a
report this was a medical
with it was a medical call was
consistent with what they
know so far so could these officers have
escalated the situation
uh if they obviously could have used
tasers if they had tasers
but they didn't have tasers but why
shoot to kill
as opposed to shoot to injure and just
prevent anything from going further
okay because you're an idiot well
floater and the answer is because that's
the stupidest thing i've ever heard
but again more important to cover the
evils of cops who didn't actually do
anything wrong than to cover what's
actually happening in the city
so the pennsylvania governor tom wolf he
called the rioting peaceful protests he
literally said this okay so here is
governor wolf
i'm my staff and have been in constant
communication since last night
with the folks in philadelphia and the
hope is that that
doesn't escalate into anything uh more
than than the peaceful protests that
that i think this kind of situation
brings out
oh well you know we we all have hopes
don't we we all have hopes but those
hopes were not justified also as it
turns out
um it turns out the police were told to
let the looters loot according to jazz
shaw writing over at hot air the mayor
of philadelphia imposed a curfew last
night in an attempt to quell the ongoing
rioting and looting
shockingly many of the people who were
already in the process of breaking any
numbers of law did not follow the orders
and set out to continue the mayhem so
why would the looters continue emptying
the shelves of all the city stores after
they'd been put on notice by the
municipal government
perhaps it's because they'd heard that
the cops had been ordered not to arrest
any looters
yes you heard that correctly the cops
were told to simply disperse the looters
and not take them into custody this
comes from one of the local fox news
reporters who heard it directly from
multiple police sources
steve keeley reporting obtained by fox
29 news
directive from philly police executive
team extremely frustrated officers both
patrolling commanders told me overnight
they were ordered not to arrest looters
just
disperse them okay that is incredible
that is incredible okay as you may
recall daniel outlaw who is the current
philadelphia police chief took the
office of police commissioner on a
promise to put an end to the
incarceration nation
that we all supposedly live in she's
been one of the biggest proponents of
the empty the jails movement in the
country
in case you weren't aware of her history
prior to coming to philadelphia she was
prior the chief of police in
portland oregon so yes it turns out
that these major cities being left to
the predations of local officials who do
not care about rioting and looting or
see the rioting and looting as justified
response to the systemic evils and
racism of america
that is a big story and it's a big story
in a swing state so naturally the media
don't want to cover it
and joe biden will be asking no tough
questions about it so joe biden
the basic part that joe biden is being
asked by the media is will you condemn
rioting and looting sure he'll condemn
writing and looting now ask him if he'll
condemn antifa no
ask him if he'll condemn black lives
matter no ask him if he'll condemn
the end to the incarceration movement
that calls for the non-arrest of people
who are engaged in rioting and looting
no he's never going to ask my favorite
is that they just
assume this is sufficient joe biden
announces he's against bad thing
oh well i'm big news there i'm sure he's
going to be a bulwark against that bad
thing happening
here's joe biden saying he doesn't like
riding and looting and everybody
cheering yay
simpson's style there is no excuse
whatsoever
for the looting and the violence none
i think to be able to protest is totally
legitimate
it's totally reasonable but i think that
the looting
is just as the victim's father
said do not do this it's not what my son
you're not helping you're hurting you're
not helping my son
he's not the victim he's the alleged
victim and that allegation is
extraordinarily weak considering he was
carrying a gun and refusing to put
carrying a knife and refusing to put it
down while approaching police officers
okay this is a it's a bad time for the
country i mean what we're watching right
now is a bad time for the country it's
not a bad time for the country
specifically because of donald trump it
is a bad time for the country because we
have a media that is utterly compliant
in a narrative that suggests that
america's so systemically racist that we
ought not cover
actual mirrors worthy events we have to
downplay newsworthy events
simply to stop trump because everybody
on the right is just that bad
the social pressure not to back anything
remotely conservative
is extremely heavy very very heavy right
now it's why there are a lot of people
who are doubting the polls we'll see if
it materializes or not
it may not materialize in support for
trump but the pressure is there
there is going to be a backlash at some
point to the social pressure
that suggests that if you want to stand
up to this stuff in any serious way
you're a bad person
because the social pressure is becoming
overwhelming just a slight example over
the last 24 hours the girl scouts
put up a social media post
congratulating amy coney barrett
it said congratulations amy coney
barrett on becoming the fifth woman
appointed to the supreme court
since its inception in 1789 and then
they put up a picture of female supreme
court justices
that included all of the various supreme
court justices who have been female
sandra day o'connor
and sonia sotomayor and ruth bader
ginsburg and elena kagan
right this drove a bunch of democrats to
immediately start yelling at the girl
scouts ayanna pressley who's a delight
she's the ringo starr of the squad
she tweeted out what kind of patch does
one earn for uplifting a woman who's the
antithesis
of justice the antithesis of amy coney
bears now the antithesis of justice
so what did the girl scouts immediately
do they took it down and they apologized
they took it they took down the tweet
and they apologized
okay because it is very very important
that they apologize for such things
they cannot be allowed to say a nice
thing about amy coney barrett such as
that she is a female who is on the
supreme court
right this is where the social pressure
is see this is why the claim is that joe
biden is going to restore an era of
normalcy
that joe biden is going to bring things
back under control the things are
bubbling out of control
because of trump and joe biden's going
to put back a sense of i don't think
that's going to happen at all
i don't think it's going to happen at
all and the reason i don't think that's
going to happen at all
is because too many liberals have
decided to make common cause with the
radical
left rather than simply assuming that
they can win a majority on basis of
their own ideas
on the basis of their own policies see
liberals in america they have a choice
right now
the choice is they can stand for open
conversation whether it's big tech
right whether it's on the social
platforms whether it's in the media they
can stand for more information being
disseminated not less information
they can stand for having discussions
with people on the right
or they can make common cause with the
folks on the radical left
the folks who are on the right may share
with them certain presumptions the
liberals
about freedom of speech and freedom of
the press the folks on the left
share political presumptions about what
they want utopia to look like
liberals have to decide whether they
prefer a country where they may not
always get their way in terms of policy
but at least
don't undermine fundamental principles
they supposedly believe in like freedom
of speech and tolerance for others
opinions
or whether they are so attached to the
policy agenda of utopian democratic
socialism that they'd rather make common
cause with a sensorious left
that hates everybody on the right so
much they'll just call them racist and
it's pretty obvious which way the
the liberals are moving they're not
moving in the direction of open
conversation
they're not moving in the direction of
having open discussion with people with
whom they disagree
they're overtly moving against that
excellent indicator of this yesterday
from jonathan chates so people have
asked me before
who are people who are liberal who i
enjoy reading sometimes and i've said
from time to time jonathan cheap right
i've actually cited jonathan jonathan
che would never say anything similar
about me this is the rule
on social media which is that if you're
a person on the right and you're nice to
somebody on the left
that's basically okay but if you're a
person on the left
and you are you're nice to somebody on
the right you're immediately excoriated
right if you're the girl scouts and you
say something nice about amy corny
barrett then you are immediately
excluded you've done something deeply
wrong
okay so jonathan chait i think can
fairly be assumed to be a mainstream
democratic liberal are he's somebody who
supposedly believes in the evils of
cancel culture he's somebody who
supposedly believes in the first
amendment and freedom of the press and
freedom of speech
he wouldn't be somebody who'd just make
common cause with the radical left right
he would be somebody who is for free and
open discussion
except that he is now engaged she is in
a campaign to basically call everybody
he disagrees with a racist which is a
way of endorsing the program of the left
once you have labeled somebody as a
racist there is no reason to have a
conversation with them
now they're in the untouchable class now
they have been put
in the basket of deplorables with whom
you may never have a conversation
and this is the this is the goal this is
what they are attempting to do so
yesterday jonathan chait tweeted out
conservatives like charles cook who's
the editor of national review and ben
shapiro used to find trump's racism
embarrassing
then they concluded they like it okay
this is
an amazing statement it's an amazing
statement so
he argues that charles cook who by the
way didn't even say that he's voting for
trump and i because i say that i'm
voting for trump even though i didn't
vote for trump in 2016.
we now embrace and love trump for being
a racist now
there's not a statement trump has made
that i think is racist that i have
defended in fact
i've called him out on any statement
that i think that he has made that is
racist so for example
when he suggested that a mexican judge
was incapable of judging a case on trump
university because of his mexican
heritage he was not in fact mexican he
was born in the united states
i said that is a racist comment hey i've
ripped trump up and down
when i think he has said something that
it doesn't matter according to jonathan
chates
anybody who is going to vote for trump
anybody who disagrees with jonathan that
trump overall is a racist
anybody who disagrees with any of that
stuff is in fact a racist
the liberals in this country the people
like joe biden they're not gonna make
common cause with people on the center
right they're not gonna make common
cause with people who are in favor of
free speech
they're not in favor of strengthening
the protections of the first amendment
they're not in favor of strength
strengthening the ability to disseminate
information they're very much in favor
of the social media campaigns
that turn every corporation every press
outlet into an instrument for their
utopian goals
that's the choice that's been put to
mainstream liberals and mainstream
liberals are failing that choice and joe
biden is a great indicator of a person
who's failing that choice do i think
that joe biden is going to defend
the rights of conservatives to be heard
on social media no i damn well don't
i can name off the top of my head a
thousand conservatives who are going to
defend the right of liberals
to disseminate their informations on
twitter but i can't name a single
democrat
who right now is willing to actually
stand up and say anything about this in
a position of power
not one this is the problem in the
country
the woke have taken over the party not
because the woke represents a majority
of the democratic party but because all
it takes is a radical minority
that is willing to sit out elections a
radical minority that is willing to use
its power in concerted ways
to convince the liberals that they ought
to side with that radical minority
rather than building some sort of
bridges with people with whom they
disagree and getting half a loaf rather
than in the entire loaf
right that is the math that the liberals
are doing right now and it's an ugly
ugly ugly math
okay meanwhile there is a piece of good
news for the trump administration
going into the election five days out
from the election the gdp
the gdp uh is uh
great this quarter it was up gdp was up
now we are still down net on the year
but that is a very very good number
right i mean
the gdp stat jumping 33 is the highest
jump in gdp in the history of the united
states that is because as lockdowns
began to alleviate
people started to go back to work people
started to go back to business people
started to live their lives again
and as people start to live their lives
again infections start to spread
the best way to limit infections is to
socially distance from people not to be
in a room for 15 minutes
an air-conditioned room for 15 minutes
with people and if you are going to be
in close contact with people
then wear a mask right we know all of
this we know all of this
but the new push is obviously we have to
shut everything down apparently forever
right this is the new push
everything must be shut down until the
end of time
is the new goal now i understand
and i've said before that i think covet
is dangerous of course covet is
dangerous it is more dangerous than the
flu it is not more dangerous than the
flu for young people
it is less dangerous than the flu for
young people but it is more dangerous
than the flu particularly for the
elderly
but kova does not justify the kind of
actions that we are seeing across europe
it does not justify the kind of actions
that we are seeing proposed in the
united states
we have to bring the hospitalization
rates down there's good news we have
some therapeutics
that are now being trotted out there's a
good study that came out of regeneron
today that study shows that the rate of
hospitalization has been reduced
by around 50 to 60 percent for people
who take regeneron early that's a the
monoclonal antibody treatment that
you've heard dr marie makari talk about
on this program from johns hopkins
university
right so there are therapeutics that are
being used they're bringing down the
death rate fairly radically
still we have to get the hospitalization
right down that means that young people
cannot affect old people so we have to
be careful
but what we are seeing now in britain
there's talk about literally having the
police
break into people's homes and break up
family gatherings
we've heard the same thing about
thanksgiving gatherings from gavin
newsom in the state of california
we are treating kovad like it is
airborne ebola it is not airborne ebola
the current statistics oncovit from the
cdc
the latest cdc estimates of infection
fatality rate by age
if you are age zero to 19 your chance of
dying from cobit is three
in one hundred thousand for every one
hundred thousand infections for people
under the age of twenty
there will be three people who die if
you're between the ages of 20 and 49 by
the way this is for all populations
right
this is not separating off the healthy
from the unhealthy so if you're healthy
your chances are way lower than this
right if you're unhealthy if you have
clinical obesity if you have diabetes if
you have serious heart issues
obviously your chances are much higher
so this doesn't striate by health
condition it's just by age
for two for if you're between the ages
of 20 and 49
then your death rate your infection
fatality rate from covid
is one in five thousand right two in ten
thousand infections so for every ten
thousand people in your age range who
are infected
two will die if you're between 50 and 69
every 995 out of 1000 infections you
will survive
five deaths per 1000. once you hit above
the age of 70 everything kills you
right once you hit above the age of 70
then there will be 5.4 deaths per 100
infections
because basically once you're above the
age of 70 then the flu can kill you also
right i mean
there's very like it's more deadly than
the flu for people who are above the age
of 70 but actually there's a less of a
differential between death rates
from flu and covid between the ages of
70 and death than there is between the
ages of 50 and 69 for example
because you're just more vulnerable when
you are of that age nonetheless we were
talking about full-scale lockdowns
nearly everywhere on earth so this shows
a couple of things one
donald trump is not actually responsible
for the spread of covet
it turns out that france is having a
massive massive breakout of cobit
germany is having a massive
break out of kobe italy is having a
massive break out of cove the eu is
getting walloped right now it turns out
the heavier you locked down in the first
place the more you're getting a spike in
covet
right now france is now going to
reimpose a nation by lockdown germany
will close bars in restaurants and
impose other restrictions for a month
in a last-ditch effort to protect
hospitals from becoming overwhelmed with
virus patients as europe battles the
second wave of the pandemic remember
germany was the big success story
it turns out covet comes for everybody
sooner or later
for months according to the new york
times european countries have tried to
slow the spread of the virus through
targeted restrictions aimed at avoiding
the tough nationwide lockdowns imposed
in the spring
but the measures have not succeeded at
halting the surge in cases and
hospitalizations putting more drastic
limits on daily life
back in play officials are prioritizing
keeping schools and some economic
activity open
in stark contrast to the spring when
movement was severely limited
president emmanuel macron argues that
officials had no choice but to impose
another lockdown
in the face of limited hospital capacity
he says much of europe is facing a
similar
situation he says that europe is being
overwhelmed by a second wave we now know
will probably be
harder and more deadly than the first
most non-essential businesses will be
closed again including bars and
restaurants movement outside the home
will be strictly limited private and
public gatherings will be banned
universities will pivot to online
classes some jobs will remain open but
the lockdowns are going to be in effect
through at least december 1st this is in
france
so obviously this is donald trump's
fault also it shows that lockdowns are
exactly what you thought they were
they're just a delay tactic
that's all they are so you can either
lock down forever or you can acknowledge
that there's a risk to living daily life
and then you can go out and live your
life and you can take precautions that
are
responsible in the uk they're going
absolutely wild in the uk the
a police commissioner now says that
officers may break into christmas family
dinners
if they flat lockdown rules which seems
like a pretty
grave violation of personal privacy for
disease
that is extremely unlikely to kill
people who are under the age of 50.
okay right right now the united states
is experiencing a surge as well
three dozen states have reported the
average number of people currently
hospitalized with cover 19
rose by at least five percent over the
past week admiral brett gerard assistant
secretary of health
says we are another critical point in
the pandemic response
and of course he encouraged people to
avoid crowded gatherings and wash your
hands a lot
the united states reported 73 000 new
cases on tuesday bringing the seven-day
average of new cases up to about 71
832. right now
there's worried about hospitalizations
which are starting to climb pretty
significantly this is actually the third
wave of hospitalizations that we've seen
we saw a giant wave at the beginning
then we saw that southern wave that
happened during the summer when people
went into air-conditioned areas
and now we are seeing a third wave the
places where we are seeing
the highest rates of newly reported
cases are exactly the places that didn't
get hit hard the first time right
basically everywhere that avoided it
is now getting walloped so north dakota
south dakota montana wisconsin wyoming
idaho utah
right states that are actually not
getting walloped right now include
florida
which got wild before and places like
new york
which is not getting hit particularly
hard there's a spike there but it's not
a spike that is
anywhere close to the the caseload in
places like north dakota
so bottom line is that this is what
everybody thought it was right it is
going to
wave through the united states it is
going to do what it does
you can take mitigating measures and
that's pretty much all you can do the
stock market took a dump yesterday
because of all of this as the lockdowns
approach that of course is not a great
shock
anthony fauci who's been unleashed to be
his pessimistic doom and gloom self
he says that it may be the end of 2021
and maybe beyond before we reach a sense
of normalcy by the way that's not going
to happen
it isn't if you think that the world is
simply going to put everything on pause
for a disease that is not killing
extraordinary rates of people under the
age of 70.
i mean it's killing when i say not
extraordinary i mean like not ebola
not mers right it is killing people at
an outsized rate compared to the flu
but you probably don't know that many
people if you're under the age of 70 who
have died of the flu
okay but here's anthony fauci saying
we're basically going to uh we're going
to be in this
stasis situation until maybe 2022.
okay here's the thing the closer you
lock people down the more you lock
people down
the less effect it's going to have
people are just going to start ignoring
it
already you can see it already you can
see that people have basically said okay
well if i get it i get it and that's
just the way it's going to work because
you cannot prevent people from living
their lives this way here's anthony
fauci
promoting doom and gloom i would imagine
at least in the united states the way
things are looking
that if we get a vaccination campaign
and by the
second or third quarter of 2021
we have vaccinated a substantial
proportion of the people
i think it will be easily by the end of
2021 and perhaps even into the next year
before we start having some semblances
of normality and it really depends on
what you mean by normal
okay well if by what we mean by normal
is normal that's not going to happen
and nobody's going to stay home until
the end of time
by borrowing money from the future in
order to stay home for a disease
that if you're under the age of 20 is
killing you at a rate of 3 per 100 000
and if you are under the age of 50
is killing you at a rate of 2 per 10 000
that's not going to happen
it just isn't but at least some folks on
the left are acknowledging what is at
stake
right here so eddie glaude who is a
commentator over on msnbc
uh he suggests that to even value
freedom is uh
is a waste of time we should just stop
it stop valuing freedom and liberty he
says that we have to stop explo
you know it's the talk of freedom and
liberty that's killing people no you can
be free
and you can live a liberated life and
you can also be responsible these things
are not
mutually exclusive but the idea of the
left is that freedom itself
is the danger which ties into freedom of
speech and every other thing that the
left believes about freedom freedom
itself is the danger here's eddie loud
saying
that the right keeps using freedom talk
as an excuse for irresponsibility
maybe the right is using freedom talk
because i don't think it's appropriate
for the government to break into my
family thanksgiving dinner because they
want to protect grandma i just don't
think that's appropriate
grandma is a sentient human being we are
all sentient human beings here is eddie
glad though
saying freedom and liberty i i presume
are bad now under these circumstances
this is the exploitation of an
ideological commitment to something
called liberty or freedom
and these and the casualty right the
collateral
damage happens to be 227
thousand amer dead americans in the name
of a certain idea of
liberty and freedom that's just nonsense
it's nonsense hundreds of thousands of
people have died in other countries with
lockdowns
with mandatory masking and the and the
idea here is that
if you like freedom and blame it on
freedom and liberty that that's not
what's going on here
it isn't okay and freedom and liberty
does not mean i have the freedom of
liberty to go cough in an old person's
face
that's not what we're talking about here
the left is pro-lockdown because the
left generally believes that freedom
is not freedom allows the freedom to do
wrong and therefore freedom itself is
the threat
that is an ideology that should not
sustain contact with
reality but it does there are a lot of
people who believe that government can
save you from everything including
yourself alrighty
we'll be back here later today for two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam's psy event
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20
liberal republicans endorse biden to
support country over
party big tech executives humiliate
themselves in senate testimony
and the anti-trump anonymous author outs
himself just days before the election
check it out on the michael noll show
[Music]